richard before we go we wanted to talk
to you about a recent death in the
family the cbs family someone on the 48
hours team josh gellman what can you
tell us about him i know just now we
were talking about him in the studio and
someone just said brian specifically
said he's one of the good ones he was
one of the good guys
he was one of the great guys
thanks for asking gail his
his title was producer but that didn't
describe him even a little he was one of
those guys whose mind was always
clicking whether he was working or
playing a lot of the visual magic that
you saw in 48 hours came out of josh's
brain and a lot of those great human
stories came out of his heart he was
also just a great friend with a razor
sharp wit
he made our stories better he made our
lives better especially the lives of his
wife christina
and his their daughter eva
josh was just a one of a kind great guy
we will miss him
miss him terribly we were privileged to
know him thanks for asking him wow it's
a beautiful remembrance that's a yeah
beautifully said about him i was very
sorry to hear it and certainly we're
thinking about his wife and his daughter
at this time it's very tough to get that
news this week